so usually you know i call you brother
van or cousin van actually
but i gotta start calling you the six
billion dollar brother
then we haven't even gotten this film
here in the u.s yet and it's already
made hundreds of millions of dollars
overseas
your whole life you pushed yourself to
be faster than don
smarter than dom stronger than don
but could you kill him
[Music]
how does that make you feel when you
know like those numbers and
how this franchise has made history well
what the numbers represent yeah is the
people
that have been affected by the film the
people
that have supported the franchise that
makes me feel um incredible and grateful
and blessed
but it also um inspires me
to reach higher and to keep on earning
it
and and making it uh worthy
of the support and loyalty that you've
shown it let's go for a little ride
you know we're celebrating 20 years of
the franchise this year too
and at this point dom is part of your
dna like he's part of you
he's part of you but so how has this
character
really kind of helped the trajectory of
your career this franchise even changed
the trajectory of your career
i might not have anticipated
the family component
yeah that i would be rewarded with yeah
by dedicating two decades to this
mythology that is
a reward that is indescribable the fact
that
i can make these movies and these
chapters
uh with people that i love uh it's
probably the biggest blessing
yeah so good and in this one like the
stakes are even higher because dom is a
dad
that's right so how did it raise the
stakes for you because you mirrored this
in real life when you became a daddy for
the first time
right that's 100 right i love the idea
that our mythology doesn't shy away from
that
yeah and i love the idea that our
mythology
allows the characters to evolve
on screen you've got people that
went 20 years ago to see the first fast
and furious
that are bringing their children
to chapter 9. and that is amazing that's
what family is
um so i feel just grateful
uh it has very much mirrored my life
yeah
um there are lines that
uh my son in the movie says that come
directly from my kids
so yeah they're but you have to even
consider the fact that every time a
child was born
i was working yeah on the fast set so
the the uncle tyrese's and the uncle
chris
and the auntie jordanas and auntie
michelle's
that's all real they were there the day
they were born i love that you talked
about your son being in this movie
playing young dom
that's right which i loved okay so take
me to that moment when he's there in
this the scene and you're watching
on the monitor what is that like for you
oh well i'm gonna walk you through this
first of all it wasn't my idea
for my son to be in this movie it was a
justin
idea was it and to be a hundred percent
honest i'm not
sure that i would have thought it was a
good idea
because i'm as you saw the movie
that's a moment when dom is in a very
emotional vulnerable and reflective
moment
what was probably the most wild
aspect of that was
he had worked 12 hours he had grinded
he had he was dedicated he was going
over his lines with the other cast
members
he's eating lunch he was bonding uh
with his young brother jacob and and his
father
in the movie um
and i was off in my space
in the dumb state of mind the thing i
remember the most about the whole
experience
was the moment that i came home and
there was a little twinkle in his eye
and he saw that daddy had returned oh
that was the moment oh you got me don't
make me cry man don't you do it
don't you make me cry because listen i i
know your heart
i know how big it is and i know how you
first of all you you would not make
another fast film
if you still weren't keeping paul's
memory alive you all do it beautifully
again
and i know that for you that has to
happen correct
that does absolutely have to happen
i can't envision making a
fast film continuing this mythology
without my brother pablo's soul being
the guiding spirit yeah
i can't even imagine how you felt when
you saw meadows instagram
pictures of you and paul with just the
word family
i just got off the phone with her oh you
say that
i literally just got off the phone with
i
that means everything yeah and
that's what family does and it's
that goes beyond the success of the
franchise
that's about the success of your soul
you have two films left
possibility maybe we can get her in one
of them we can see
her
i'ma take your non-answer as my answer